Ace became a top commander on a Yonko crew. Luffy
became a Yonko in just over two years. And Sabo
rose to the position of commander in chief of
the revolutionary army with the sole purpose of
taking down the world nobles. But what if instead
of seeking freedom from the world government, all
three boys instead JOINED the marines TOGETHER in
order to make the world a better place that way?
And this story simply must begin back
in the Goa Kingdom, where these three
boys grew up. Now from chapter one,
we know that Luffy was inspired to
become a great pirate when he was saved from
certain death by his mentor Shanks. However,
we also know that during this time,
Garp had been training Luffy - well,
if you can call throwing him into the jungle
or tying him to a balloon training - with the
specific purpose of turning him into a marine.
And we can assume he did something similar
with Ace since he “raised” him as well. However,
both of them were dead set on becoming pirates.
But for this scenario, let’s imagine that
something changed about their childhood.
Maybe Garp was actually a good grandparent and
spent time with the boys, which made them want
to follow in his footsteps. Or I think a more
likely situation could have been that the village
where Luffy grew up might have been attacked by
a ruthless band of pirates. And it is reasonable
to assume that Shanks is out at sea so there is
no one to protect the village. We could even say
that these pirates set fire to the forest on Mt.
Corvo, which would affect Ace also since he was
living up there with the mountain bandits. So with
the pirates running free, there is no hope for the
village until this marine admiral pulls up on
his chilly bicycle and casually wipes out the
pirates. Which is a major turning point because
it shows Luffy and Ace exactly how important the
Marines are to the world. And this single moment
ultimately inspires them to become Marines in
the future. I also think the boys could have also
pretty easily convinced Sabo to join the Marines
with them since Sabo already has a good heart and
wants to free people, which he can easily do as a
marine. Let’s just assume that he doesn’t sail
out to sea on his own and get himself blown up.
Now we don’t know for sure what
age people can join the Marines,
but we do know that this pink-haired
kid was sixteen when he joined,
so let’s assume that older teenagers
can join. So just to keep things easy,
let’s say Ace and Sabo join when they are
seventeen, which is the same age that Ace
originally set out to become a pirate. And if
these two are joining the Marines, there is no
way Luffy is staying behind, so Garp is forced
to let the fourteen year old join as well.
And as they begin their climb through the marine
ranks there are a few very important things to
keep in mind. First, Luffy would probably still
have the straw hat. But a major question we will
answer later on is just how long Shanks will let
him keep it if he remains a marine. Also, you may
have serious doubts about Luffy ever following
someone else’s orders, but this is where I should
mention that their personalities would probably be
slightly changed. Luffy will still be adventurous,
but if he knows he wants to be a marine, he would
probably eventually get used to the idea of taking
orders. Also, Ace will still be hot headed and
Sabo will want to free people from oppression,
just like they were in the original story. Plus,
even though they are supposed to follow orders,
do you really think that is going to happen
all the time? *chuckle* We’ll see how long that
lasts. Also, keep in mind that the timeline
is also not the same as the normal story,
since Luffy didn’t start his pirate journey
for another three years into the future.
So let’s kick off this marine adventure where
every recruit begins life… as chore boys.
Because unlike when Garp personally trained
Koby, I think Garp would be sick and tired
of these three troublemakers so they would
just be assigned to some random navy base and
start at the very bottom of the marine ranks.
However, this probably won’t last long because
these rambunctious kids are probably so awful at
chores that Garp would probably just throw them
into battle since they aren’t good for anything
else. So it’s off to the ships to fight pirates
in the East Blue. And I think they would stay
this way for several years, working their way
up the ranks from Chore Boy to Seaman Recruits
because of their impressive fighting capabilities.
One other major change is that Ace most
likely wouldn’t have his Fire devil fruit,
since he only found it after setting out
as a pirate. This means that Luffy is the
only one of the three with a devil
fruit. Not that it matters though,
because they are all insanely strong and
capable of taking out random pirates,
though I do wonder if Ace would eventually
choose to use a sword or other bladed weapon.
This simple life can’t continue forever though, so
let’s say that two years have passed. Ace and Sabo
are now nineteen and they have been promoted to
Petty Officers, while Luffy at age sixteen remains
a Seaman First Class. Now you might be wondering,
“Manu, Koby moved from a recruit to being a
captain in that same amount of time, so shouldn’t
these three move up way faster?” Which is a fair
point, but also remember that Koby had personal
training from Garp, so that along with Garp’s
recommendations probably moved him up the ranks a
bit faster than normal. Plus Oda probably had to
somewhat keep pace with pirate Luffy’s warp speed
advancement, which isn’t the case in this scenario
That is all going to change very quickly though
because we have to remember that in any military
organization, you can’t stay with your friends
forever. So it is at this point the childhood
friends are split up. Sabo is sent to work with
the awful Captain Morgan at Shells Town, which
is not going to turn out very well as we’ll see
in just a moment. Ace is assigned to Lieutenant
Commander Fullbody. And Luffy is assigned to
Commodore Pudding Pudding. But even though the
boys are separated, I can just imagine that they
would all still want to compete with each other to
see who can get promoted the quickest. Especially
Luffy, since he is already behind the other two.
Now, keep in mind that even though Sabo is
a marine, he would still have his strong
sense of doing what is right, so when he
is put under the command of the abusive
and - if we’re being honest - straight
up evil Captain Morgan I don’t think that
Sabo would put up with it for long. And
while I’m not sure if this marine version
of Sabo would challenge Morgan to a
fight because of marine regulations,
I think he would definitely collect evidence and
submit a report to the marine higher ups. Then
I could imagine Morgan finding out about it and
then trying to just kill Sabo on his own. Which
would be the perfect chance for Sabo to crush
Morgan and get him kicked out of the Marines.
Then let’s shift over to Ace because if he is
working with Fullbody then they will probably
be dining at the floating restaurant Baratie
quite frequently. Which is perfect for Ace
who can eat his fill during his visits here, I
think he would also have a chance to run into
some pretty strong pirates who are coming for
the tasty grub. And even though it is still
about a year before Don Krieg showed up in the
normal timeline, Ace can still gain a reputation
as a defender of the floating restaurant. Which
would probably make him great friends with Sanji.
However, while the older two are making names
for themselves, it is Luffy who truly makes the
first major splash as a marine. Because let’s say
another year has passed and now we are basically
caught up to the timeline at the start of the
series. Luffy is still working for Pudding Pudding
which eventually brings him to Arlong Park,
just like what happened in chapter 75. However,
while Arlong easily killed the marines then, this
time they have Luffy. And while it might be tough
for Luffy to fight all of the Arlong pirates by
himself, we have to remember that he has already
been out at sea for three years and should be much
stronger than he was when he started his journey.
So in his heroic moment, Luffy wipes
out the Arlong pirates and saves Nami’s
village. Which means that he would likely
befriend the orange haired navigator,
who would then likely join the marines since
her village is safe and her adopted mother
Bellemere was also a marine. So while we are
missing out on many of the other straw hats,
at least Nami is joining
Luffy in the marine ranks.
Now these heroics get Luffy promoted up to
Ensign. But he’s not the only one because
Ace and Sabo have also scored their
own impressive victories. For example,
Sabo and his new commander Ripper have gone
and rescued Orange Town from the invading
Buggy Pirates. Ace also takes out Don Krieg
when the starving pirate tries to take over
the Baratie. Unfortunately, no one is around
to save Usopp’s village, so sorry Usopp fans,
it looks like his tradition of
dying in these What Ifs continues.
Which means that Ace and Sabo are joining Luffy in
the lowest rank of officer in the Marines. Oh boy,
let’s just hope they don’t actually get to give
orders to anyone. But with this promotion comes
new assignments. Ace and Luffy are both
placed under Captain Smoker in Loguetown
while Sabo is assigned to Captain Hina, who
is already in the Grand Line.And even though
Smoker was originally happy to stay
at Loguetown in the original story,
I think that with his two newest Ensigns
constantly annoying him to go to the Grand Line,
he would probably agree just so
those two would shut up about it.
And now that we are in the Grand Line, Ace, Sabo,
and Luffy are going to move through the ranks
very quickly. Though as we’ll see very soon, it's
not always in a positive direction. Because while
they patrol the seas under their new captains,
I’d like to imagine that Luffy still runs into
Vivi at some point. Maybe they come to Whiskey
Peak and meet her there, but however it happens,
Vivi would likely tell them all about her
country’s troubles after seeing how strong
Luffy and Ace are. Of course, Luffy and Ace
want to go right away to take down the Sandman,
but Smoker says they cannot interfere with
a Warlord because they are basically immune
from the Marines. However, the captain does
agree to go to Alabasta, just to be around
in case anything goes wrong. Sabo and Hina also
arrive, and as the civil war kicks into high gear,
the three boys simply cannot sit around and let
all these innocent people die. So in their first
major act of insubordination, Ace, Sabo, and
Luffy work together to take down Crocodile,
which they somehow manage to do,
even though he is a logia fruit user.
Luffy might also meet Robin. And although
she wouldn’t let him become her friend,
Luffy would probably let her go.
He could even mention that if she
is looking for a crew to help her then
maybe she should try to find Shanks,
but we’ll see exactly how Robin’s
story goes later on in the video.
However, this whole situation causes a huge
headache for the world government. And these
three marines are headed for a ton of trouble
because even though the rulers of Alabasta
officially thank the three boys, they are still
demoted back down to Warrant Officers. However,
at this point, the marine higher-ups
see great potential in the three boys,
so I think it makes sense now if they were each
assigned to an admiral for special training. Which
is going to supercharge their advancements,
just like we saw when Garp trained Koby.
They would likely pair up the two most
hot-headed, so Ace would go with Akainu.
Luffy gets paired with Kizaru - by the way, I
would absolutely love to see how this training
would go since they are both pretty much
air-heads. And that leaves Sabo with Aokiji,
which is also a VERY interesting
match because Aokiji, just like Sabo,
is starting to have some serious questions about
the corruption in the world government system.
So this means they would definitely learn basic
haki. I also think Luffy would develop some of
his Gear techniques, which all results in a
HUGE power boost for all three, especially
because they now have the fundamental tools
to fight with any devil fruit user in the sea.
So while those boys are getting their own
personal training arc, let’s shift to other
events going on in the world. Because even
with Ace, Sabo, and Luffy all in the Marines,
I still think that Blackbeard would be able to
backstab this guy and steal his Darkness Logia
fruit. From here he would still have his same plan
to become a warlord. However, instead of being
able to capture Luffy as was his original plan, or
take out Ace when he came for revenge, Blackbeard
will have to find some other way to convince
the World Government to make him a Warlord.
However, to keep things fairly similar to the
original events, let’s assume that he still
targets members of the Whitebeard pirates. Maybe
he takes out some of the lower ranking commanders,
and this increased level of aggression
could see someone like Marco the Phoenix
come after Blackbeard. And if Blackbeard could
capture him and hand him over to the Marines,
then we have all the ingredients we need
for Marineford. Although I certainly think
Blackbeard would have a harder time sneaking
into Impel Down to break out the level six
prisoners since Luffy isn’t there to cause the
massive prison break. The darkness fruit user
might be able to come up with some other
plan though, such as the hypnosis user,
Laffitte, somehow sneaking in and
causing their own prison break.
Anyway, with Marco taking Ace’s place on
the execution stand, Whitebeard would still
likely come to try to rescue his right hand
man, which perfectly sets the stage for Ace,
Sabo, and Luffy to demonstrate their new powers
in a war that unfolds much differently than the
original story. Because we have to keep in
mind that Marco was a key fighter for the
Whitebeard pirates during the war. He even took
on admirals, so with him on the execution stand,
that is a massive loss for the pirates. Plus
no Impel Down prisoners to help the pirates.
And while I don’t think Ace, Sabo, and Luffy
are ready to take on Whitebeard yet, I do think
they would do well against the Whitebeard
commanders such as Jozu, Vista, and Izou.
Which all results in the Marines winning this
fight much easier than in the original story.
Marco gets executed. Which honestly
pains me to say since he is one of
my all-time favorite characters.
Whitebeard’s defeat doesn’t change,
which allows Blackbeard to swoop in and
steal his devil fruit. Although it is
possible that the Marines may be able to
keep Blackbeard away, I believe this was
Blackbeard’s ultimate goal all along, so I think
he would somehow figure out a way to get it done.
Which means this is where things turn
dark. Because with Whitebeard dead,
I think Akainu and other marines would continue
to fight against the remaining pirates,
causing way more bloodshed than in the
original war. This is particularly hard
to take for someone like Sabo, and Luffy
would also probably hate to see lives
needlessly wasted. Which means that everyone is
relieved when Shanks shows up to stop the war.
But this might not actually be as good for Luffy
as you might think. Because remember that Shanks
trusted Luffy with his legendary straw hat because
he assumed that Luffy would become a pirate, and
he likely even knew that Luffy had the potential
to become Joy Boy. So now that Luffy is clearly
established as a marine, we have to ask what would
Shanks do? Well, I think the most likely thing
after he stops the fighting is that he gives Luffy
a warning. He would say something along the lines
of “That hat belongs in the hands of the future
pirate king” and he might demand that Luffy leave
the Marines or give up the hat. Which brings up
an interesting dilemma for Luffy. He was inspired
by Shanks as a kid, but eventually decided to
become a marine after seeing evil pirates attack
his village. So while I’m sure he still feels
some call to adventure, in this scenario he will
reject Shanks’ warning and stay a marine. Which
leaves Shanks with two options. Try to eventually
convince Luffy to become a pirate, or kill him
so that his devil fruit can be reincarnated.
However, I just can’t see Shanks taking
out Luffy here, especially after he just
stopped the fighting, so for now he zips in,
steals the straw hat back, and then leaves.
Which would still leave Luffy furious, but he
would probably be held back by Sabo and Ace.
Now with Marineford over, Whitebeard is dead and
his crew is shattered. Blackbeard is basically a
Yonko at this point. And Ace, Sabo, and Luffy
are all promoted to Captain based on their
feats during the war. This promotion grants
them a bit more freedom with their own ships
and crews. And the first thing they do with
that freedom is subscribe to this channel,
which you can do too by pressing
that shiny red subscribe button.
However, there are even more changes coming to the
world. Because even though there wouldn’t be a two
year time skip, Akainu and Aokiji would still have
their legendary duel. Aokiji would of course lose
and leave the Marines, which is a major blow to
all three of the boys since Aokiji saved Ace and
Luffy back at the start of this What If, and the
icy admiral was the one who trained Sabo. So hmm,
wonder if we’ll see him later. That of course
means we have some new admirals to pick,
and while Luffy immediately volunteers,
he is passed over. But don’t worry,
just wait until you see the truly epic battle
that earns him this promotion later on.
This takes the boys into the New World, where
they really start to shine. Over the two years,
they battle countless strong pirates, growing
stronger and developing their haki. Luffy and Ace
might also unlock their conqueror’s haki at some
point, though it has never been confirmed if Sabo
has this ability. They might also become friends
with Zoro, who in this timeline has become an
strong bounty hunter - funny we haven’t seen
one of those before – and between Zoro and
the three young Captains, they make something
of a competition out of taking down members
of the worst generation like Captain Kid, who
is particularly ruthless, the straw man Basil
Hawkins, and even perhaps Jewelry Bonney, who
the marines were extra focused on recapturing.
And all these feats eventually see them
rise to the rank of Vice-Admirals. Not
bad for a bunch of kids, but just
wait until you see what comes next.
I think Luffy might also meet Rayleigh
at some point, and just like Shanks,
I think the former right hand of the
pirate king would try to convince Luffy
to become a pirate. Which might actually be
starting to look more attractive to Luffy,
especially as he sees more of the corruption of
the world government. For example, he might want
to take a more active role in taking down the
Yonko, but the marine leadership won’t let him.
However, Luffy says orders be damned because when
he, Ace, and Sabo join Fujitora in Dressrosa and
they see all of the horrible things that
Doflamingo has done, I can’t see anyone
stopping them from taking down the corrupt
Warlord. And while this saves the kingdom,
their actions draw the wrath of the fleet
admiral Akainu, just like Fujitora did in
the original story, which gets them
banned from all marine bases for now.
But that doesn’t bother them, and I think around
this time they would also reunite with the former
admiral Kuzan, who tells them a bit about why he
left and what he is planning to do in the future.
At this point, Luffy and Sabo are tempted to join
him, especially Sabo, but Ace convinces them to
stay and remain loyal to the marines because
Ace in particular doesn’t want to leave the
relationships he has developed with many of his
comrades in the marines. However, the more time
Luffy spends in the New World, the more tempting
it becomes to try to learn about the One Piece.
Which means that when Kuzan leaves them with
one other very important piece of information
they immediately set off on their most
important mission yet. Apparently,
Kuzan has met with Nico Robin and she has been
secretly going around collecting information
on the poneglyphs. Kuzan tells them where she
is and that she would like to see Luffy again
because she has some information to tell
him. So Luffy, Ace, and Sabo go to meet
with Robin. And this single event is going to
have major consequences for the entire world.
Because when the boys meet with Robin on some
random island, they are met with a shocking
surprise. Blackbeard and his crew have also
arrived and are ransacking the entire island
trying to find Robin. This instantly puts
Luffy, Sabo, and Ace into battle mode,
and they square off against the Blackbeard
Pirates. But with just the three of them
against the Yonko crew, they would probably
have a very hard time coming out on top.
However, this is just the start of this clash
because Kuzan, who at this point has rejected
Blackbeard’s invitation, shows up to help the
three marines. And he’s not alone. Because
even though he left the Marines, he still wants
to bring peace to the world, which led him to
warn the Marines that something might happen on
this island. So not only does Kuzan arrive, but
also the three admirals - Kizaru, Greenbull, and
Fujitora - show up to stamp out the Yonko threat.
Which definitely turns the battle in the Marines
favor. That is until another major player joins
the conflict. You see, ever since Luffy, Ace,
and Sabo took out Doflamingo, the Yonko Kaido
has been out for their blood because they ruined
his artificial devil fruit production. And let’s
say he somehow follows them to this island and
joins the insane battle. Which at this point
this island is probably going to be destroyed,
but the end of the battle brings some hope for
the future. Because I think the three admirals
would be able to combine to take out Kaido,
but not without suffering casualties. Plus
Blackbeard is known for backstabbing, so I
think it is fair to say that even though Kaido
gets taken out, all three admirals are killed.
But of course that leaves our three young
heroes, who would surely awaken some of their
advanced levels of haki. Although I’m not sure
if Luffy would ever unlock Gear 5 as a marine,
but at this point I think they are admiral level
fighters on their own, so their combined strength,
plus the help of Kuzan should be enough to
eventually defeat Blackbeard and end the conflict.
Which would certainly throw the world into chaos.
Two Emperors defeated. Three admirals killed. The
entire world would be in shock. However, I
think the Marines would wisely promote Ace,
Sabo, and Luffy to admirals right away since
they are now basically the strongest marines.
And even though these three might be tired
of the corruption in the World Government,
at least as admirals they might be able to
have some influence on the marines. This
also probably means that Ace and Sabo get to pick
from the World Government’s stock of devil fruits,
although we don’t know exactly how
that process works. Regardless they
would probably grow even stronger
with new overpowered devil fruits
But now with the world in chaos, the race to find
the One Piece heats up even more. And as Luffy is
out fighting the flood of pirates seeking the
treasure, he is met by none other than Red-Hair
Shanks, who has come with another challenge. If
Luffy can defeat Shanks, then the Red-Hair captain
will leave him alone for good. But if Shanks
wins, then Luffy must leave the Marines and
chase after the One Piece because Shanks believes
it is his destiny. And if you want to see exactly
how this legendary battle between Luffy and Shanks
could go, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching, and
I’ll see you in the next one.